[Music]
the first call came on tuesday evening
local time
there'd been a shooting north of atlanta
at young's asian massage parlor
then an hour later another this time in
atlanta at gold spa
as police responded a third call came in
reporting gunfire from across the road
at aromatherapy spa
the crime scenes were all massage
parlors and the majority of the victims
were women of asian descent they're
really nice girls
they just do great massages they do
great massages over here so it's just
unfortunate
they had shot three ladies at them in
front of the massage we're not in front
of the massage but at the massage
building
and that he had gotten also shot but he
wasn't he hadn't passed away or anything
he got sent
he's in the hospital police have
arrested a 21 year old and charged him
with killing eight people
they're investigating to see if the
shooter was specifically targeting asian
americans
which would make it a hate crime and
increase the charges
south korea's foreign minister confirmed
that four of the victims were of korean
descent
nothing's going to be ruled out we're
conducting a homicide a multiple
homicide investigation so
wherever the evidence leads us that's
where the investigators will go
extreme pride that's i'm here you got
a lot of the command staff zone 2
commander so it is extreme priority for
us
crimes targeting asian americans have
risen dramatically
since the beginning of the coronavirus
pandemic
former president donald trump
controversially called it the china
virus
president joe biden addressed the
attacks in a speech last week
vicious hate crimes against asian
americans
who've been attacked harassed blamed and
scapegoated
they're forced to live in fear for their
lives just walking down streets in
america
it's wrong it's un-american and it
must stop a report by the organization
stop aapi hate detailed 3 800 attacks
against asian americans in the last 12
months
more than half were against people of
chinese or korean descent
now after what happened in georgia it's
clear more needs to be done
to prevent attacks like these charlotte
ballas
al jazeera